Rumble and slim aren't big snackers,
but when they do request something,
I usually make it.
So today they requested some chips and guacamole and some popsicles.
I got started on making my dough for my tortillas
by combining some corn flour with some warm water
before forming them into little balls and pressing them flat.
I placed them in hot skillet and fried them until they puffed up
and then transferred them over to a kitchen towel to keep them warm.
In the meantime, I moved on to making my popsicles.
I decided to make some lemon basil popsicles,
so I juiced all of my lemons
before moving on to making my simple syrup
by combining some water, sugar,
and a splash of maple syrup.
I let that come to a boil.
While that was boiling, I finally chopped my basil.
Once my mixture came to room temperature,
I poured in my lemon juice and my basil
before transferring it over to popsicle molds.
Put the lid on top
and pop these in the freezer for about three to four hours.
And in the meantime got started on making my guacamole.
Mashed up some avocado and kept the pits in to keep it fresh
before squeezing on some lime juice.
I chopped up some tomatoes,
some onions,
cilantro before putting all of that in the bowl with my avocado.
I seasoned it with some salt,
cumin, and some more lime juice before giving that a good mix,
making sure Everything is combined this point.
I cut up my tortillas and fried them until they were golden brown,
and while they were still hot,
I sprinkled them with some salt.
Kids couldn't wait,
so I got the popsicles out and gave them one before plating the chips,
and they absolutely loved it.